one more time  one more  I'm queen Bart of the hard rock trolls  I'm here to take your sister ring bro we  lose our string we lose our music I'm  gonna unite the six strings and destroy  all music except for one  I can't believe another queen would use  her power for evil these other trolls  aren't like us they dance different they  sing different  [Music]  thrown in defense  if barb collects all the strings our  music will be destroyed forever we're  gonna need a battle plan and weapons  violence never solves a problem branch  well how are we gonna hug our way out of  this one I will protect you no matter  what i pinky promise you can't go back  on a pinky  Oh pinkie promise  we need to go undercover with  only rock trolls are allowed back yeah  we are genuine hard rock earth cool jazz  paralyzed  [Music]  you